listen to this humiliating attempt at an
interview what I asked you the question
why are you
seems like you're a Poe
what do you say to that
well I disagree with that I lowered
taxes in Arkansas
Republicans surpluses
you've got to listen to me as well
you've got to listen as well we balance
the budget that's what Republicans do we
lead in this country yeah but did you
make fun of a disabled reporter do you
pretend do do you pretend weightlift to
attack trans people during your rallies
that's what the party wants now look at
my record Lawrence Governor I just went
through your record here and as I said
and I gave you credit for the normal
Republican positions you're right in
line but this is a new Republican party
thank you so much for your time sir